so so the statement means right
women we have the right if we get
pregnant we have the right not to be
mothers right yeah should men then in
the name of equality have the right not
to be fathers their wallet their choice
they can sign off on child support why
no because if you had sex with a woman
you fully know well that one of the
consequences is that you will fully like
pregnant her and you have a child so you
have to look after child as that's your
responsibility your sperm your
responsibility okay you can't run away
from that okay i don't understand why
people in their mind think it's a right
to run away from the child that's a
child you're leaving them with so much
trauma having no like dad and everything
that will leave them with severe like
ideas of how they think about men
because i'm not talking about my
perspective i've seen people's
perspective with no fathers they act in
a certain way with people that have a
father like in contrast with people who
have a father and it's not right so if
you're a man
what's the question again
i can see i feel like so obviously like
mothers and fathers they're equal to
some degree yeah but i feel like like as
a mother like the like the like what
mothers experience like when they're
like pregnant when they give birth like
everything they experience it's too a
whole different degree than what like a
father would experience and it's like
like i get like mothers and fathers they
both like they they might love their
child to the same degree they might be
present
in the child's life to the same degree
but it's like what like it's it's easier
for a dad to leave than it is for a
mother to leave because yeah
your mother has to go through to give
birth yeah so emotional support you're
meant to be there for emotional support
do you know what i know like they're
pushing the child and i know that and i
know this is this is like okay maybe not
all guys are like this but do you know
how many men are there they're the ones
that are like oh i don't want to use a
condom or does it fit me oh i'm too big
they use all these so yeah so the
argument you guys are making i could
very similarly say the same thing to
women like you choose who you sleep with
you get to pick if the guy wears a
condom or not so so to me it's like in
the name of equality shouldn't they have
the same rights we do yeah
but but no you just argue so i'm saying
like if i if i if we have an accidental
pregnancy okay if i let's say i have a
man i don't i know it's shocking but but
let's say and i and i get pregnant on
accident right so neither of us planned
this we didn't we don't want this kid
but i said i can't have an abortion
because some girls can't and he says i
don't want to be a father shouldn't he
have the same right to leave that i do
if if i leave because i can give up the
kid for adoption too i think i feel like
if the woman decides to have the baby i
feel like the father he should have the
right to be like okay i don't want to be
like in this child's life i want to
leave i feel like he should still pay
the child support like he should have to
like
like he can like sign his rights away to
the child be like i'm never but the
thing is he has to promise that he'll
never come back randomly because what
fathers love to do they love to come
back maybe like 10 15 years later and
then decide okay i'm ready to be a dad
you don't get to choose when you're
ready where is the responsibility on
women though for the men we choose to
sleep with what do you mean by that so
so like a lot of times what i see is i
see girls that pick men to sleep with
that really aren't husbands and they're
not fathers and they know damn well
they're not husbands and they're not
fathers and they get pregnant and they
wanna and they wanna and they want like
all this sympathy and now they get a
check
right and so and so the problem with the
laws the way it is is they're they're
incentivizing women to get kids off of
rich guys so i had a guy that sat down
earlier and he said i was rich and this
girl like got trapped me with a baby
because she said she was on birth
control and i understand like he should
have taken more precautions but a man
can do everything right say say drake
right you remember what happened with
drake yeah so he but he didn't right but
like let's think about it right do you
really think he didn't think to wrap it
up with the i'm gonna say cornstar like
you really think he did when he's he's
been he's a he's a player right he knows
he knows she's a corn star he probably
did she probably stole it
like why do you think he's doing in the
future like stuff like that isn't okay
like definitely i i don't think that
like you know when when she went behind
his back and tried to like impregnate
herself stuff like that isn't okay but
the whole thing is like okay well you
chose to have sex with this guy but like
you chose to have sex with him too we
chose to have sex with him but like
consenting to sex isn't the same as
consenting to having a baby but some
women just don't want like
they might not want to have a baby but
they don't want to have abortion more
than they did when have a baby do you
know what i mean right so then they have
adoption so they could still choose not
to be a mother
but i don't think you understand the
whole adoption process one adoption like
is so fast
adoption the system is so far and i can
understand like as a woman like you
don't understand how hard it is for some
women to really give their baby away
even if they in that moment after you've
given birth you've been through these
nine months you've cried this baby like
you're holding this baby and you don't
want to give it away but you know that's
what you have to do it's a really like
difficult situation and even if you give
that baby away like a lot of the
adoption system it's so [ __ ] like it's
not it's not necessarily they think that
they're giving their baby away it's like
the best possible option but that's not
always the best option and people's
argument is like how could you it's the
baby like they might not have a good
life but babies they don't even gain
consciousness until like how many months
old so a baby being a baby being aborted
the baby doesn't know that it's being a
boy if it hasn't lived do you know what
i mean yeah i feel like i'm just trying
rubbish
okay i'm just curious like just going
with this logic right do you think like
the a week before she gives pregnancy
because it's her body her choice she
should be able to have an abortion i
think i think if if it's like a week
before she's about to give birth if the
doctors tell her okay
when you give birth you're gonna like
i'm preaching that's not even that's not
even legal it's not even legal but if
we're like debating whether it should be
okay or not if we could do a month right
we could i'm just saying like at what
point at what point she should be able
to support the baby like early on yes
two weeks early like you just got
pregnant yeah one to two weeks you
killed the baby right then there's no
that's not long enough though babe three
weeks
do you know how it takes a woman maybe
like two weeks to even figure out that
she's pregnant four weeks and then she
kills off that's the like the longest in
the uk it's like six weeks it's six
months in the uk months
so yeah so so it's actually crazy you
caught you could kill child 24 weeks
no so so crazy crazy stat the earliest
child to survive a pregnancy is 21 weeks
and it's illegal up to 24. seriously yes
and it's free here i feel like before
she should like abort it but not after
that like that feels wrong i think i
didn't i bought it after she's given
birth yeah well no well i'm saying the
reason i asked was because you said the
baby's not conscious till like six
months so they won't know right so when
you said that i'm thinking okay well
then it sounds like you could abort it
afterwards
baby after it's been born i wouldn't
just clear it out
i'm not sure i'm not going to edit this
so i'm going to keep yeah
yeah um i don't know i just think i just
think like because obviously i've never
been in that position so i'm not going
to try and like
judge how women will feel in that
position because you i love look people
love to give that opinion on this and
that and the other but they've never
been in that situation so you can say
you believe in this but when you're in
that situation your opinions might
change completely so that's why i just
feel like everyone should just have the
choice i don't know i i don't get what
the question is so what is the question
the question is matt should men have the
choice and that's that's what that's
what i'm talking about
um
solution i feel like it's not like it's
not it shouldn't always be like okay
just give up for adoption then i feel
like it's there's too much to debate
about for that so so i want to tell you
guys or do you have time or do you have
to go i don't know how much
okay okay okay
okay no worries no worries you guys are
actually great i really enjoy talking to
people that i have different opinions
with and like we can have a civil nice
conversation it's not it's not always
like that so really appreciate it pearl
nice to meet you nice to meet you so um
today we're asking people the question
people in london so since women have the
right to choose right we have the right
to get an abortion for free in london up
to six months
should men have the right to a financial
abortion where they can sign off their
rights